A blurry photograph of a man in a black cowl
is taped to the wall.
A black knife held by a tattooed hand pierces
his face.
“You want him dead?”
Able asked.
“Dealt with,” his Foundation handler replied.
“Same thing…”
Able said, and laughed.
The helicopter was ready to go outside.
It was another rainy night, almost all of
them were.
Plumes of black smoke billowing from factories
on the far side of the city, blotting out
the already darkened sky and plunging Gotham
into deeper shadow.
But those shadows, that darkness, were something
the twisted underbelly had come to fear.
The dark was a tool that one man used to prey
on those who enacted injustice on the innocent.
Every shadowy alley, or flutter of movement
atop a roof, made every thief and murder on
the streets of Gotham take pause, think twice.
Batman had been trailing the movements of
suspicious cargo trucks moving in and out
of the city.
Some were decoys, driving around with empty
containers and changing their routes every
night to throw the World’s Greatest Detective
off the trail.
But those were just a distraction, a theatrical
deception being deployed so that the real
cargo could be smuggled in undetected.
Bane, a muscle-bound mercenary with the guise
of a luchador, was one of Batman’s most
physically imposing enemies.
For weeks, he had been stockpiling Venom,
a strength-enhancing compound, somewhere in
the city.
And now, Batman had picked up the trail; the
trucks weren’t distributing the Venom, that
was being done by a network of low-level street
thugs posing as motorcycle delivery drivers.
Swooping through the night sky, watching one
of the bikers from above, there was something
else playing on the Dark Knight’s mind.
Recently, he’d gotten the feeling he was
being watched.
At first, the man under the cowl – billionaire
philanthropist Bruce Wayne – had chalked
it up to paranoia, a side effect of his nightly
escapades as the Caped Crusader.
His trusted butler and confidant Alfred had
even suggested as much.
But as the weeks rolled on, Batman couldn’t
shrug the notion that every move he made,
every case he helped Commissioner Gordon solve,
every battle with the worst of Gotham’s
rogue’s gallery, that somebody was studying
him.
Already, Bruce had a list of potential suspects,
the likely candidates for who were having
him followed.
So, he gradually began paying them all visits
as his alter ego.
The larger of the city’s mob families, the
Falcones, denied any involvement.
With their leader Carmine Falcone currently
behind bars, the rest of the family were laying
low to avoid being arrested themselves.
Next came Hugo Strange, a brilliant but unhinged
scientist whom had been obsessed with Batman
for a number of years.
Bruce had worried that Hugo had finally cracked
the secret of his true identity.
But the despicable doctor also refuted that
he was the one having the Dark Knight followed.
The next possible culprit on the list was
Amanda Waller, a powerful and high-ranking
government operative, strategic genius, and
another of Batman’s rivals.
Known to some as The Wall, she was responsible
for a number of shady, covert operations that
not even the Caped Crusader knew about.
Waller dealt in secrets, and seemed just as
likely to be having Batman tailed in order
to pick up dirt on the detective.
But, as with Strange and the Falcones, Amanda
Waller denied all of the Dark Knight’s claims;
the heartbeat scanners built into his cowl’s
eyepieces confirmed that they had all been
telling the truth.
Shrugging the notion off, Batman focused on
following the biker transporting Venom across
the city, silently gliding between skyscrapers
with his cape.
He followed the smuggler all the way to an
abandoned chemical processing plant, formerly
owned by a company called ACE Chemical.
He suspected that was where Bane and his thugs
had established a base of operations, using
the plant’s leftover equipment to refine
the Venom, the source of Bane’s inhuman
strength.
Scanning through the rooftop with his cowl’s
x-ray capabilities, from a distance Batman
spotted a group of armed men unloading boxes.
They were acting under the command of a larger
figure: Bane himself.
But then, it appeared a new, unidentified
figure had come striding into the building,
met with hostility as Bane’s forces drew
their weapons.
Whoever this was, he clearly wasn’t with
them.
Suddenly, just as Batman fired his grappling
hook to swing onto the roof of the chemical
plant, all-out chaos erupted inside.
Down below, watched intently by Batman as
he slipped inside, staying concealed in the
rafters, the new figure had begun violently
attacking Bane and his men.
The man was lean, shirtless, around his late
twenties, with grey eyes and a mess of jet
black hair.
His entire body was covered in tattoos depicting
arcane runes and occult imagery on his olive
skin.
In his hands had appeared a pair of sharp,
black blades, seemingly from nowhere.
To some, he was Hevel ben Adam, the Butcher
of the West, the Great Traitor and First Sword
of Daevon.
But to the ones that had sent him there, he
was SCP-076-2: Able.
He charged towards the group of thugs as they
opened fire, their bullets missing as Able
moved with incredible speed.
With a strong upward swing of both his swords,
he cleaved the nearest two mercenaries’
weapons into broken pieces, as if their guns
were made of plastic, not metal.
Able brought both swords slicking downwards,
felling both men simultaneously.
Another nearby turned and ran, only to be
caught by one of Able’s blades as the barbaric
warrior hurled it through the air.
Watching from above, Batman was taken aback.
It was rare for him to be so alarmed by a
display of violence, especially given he had
devoted his life to crime fighting.
But the figure below was taking on Bane’s
men singlehandedly, with such speed and aggression,
that it gave the Caped Crusader pause.
As much as he abhorred killing, Batman held
back to observe this new adversary, as Able
squared up against Bane himself.
The luchador charged at him with the unbridled
rage of a snarling, feral animal, while Able
leaped into battle with equal ferocity.
His hand reached into a tiny dimensional rift,
a hole in space out of which he retrieved
an extra weapon that he swung directly at
Bane’s head.
The imposing muscle monster caught the blade
in his huge hand, blocking the blow.
He lifted Able off the ground, his own hand
still gripping the sword by its hilt, and
was about to deliver a crippling punch that
would have sent the barbarian flying.
That is, had he not slipped another sword
seemingly out of thin air and used it to slice
through the blade that Bane had in his grip.
Batman had only ever seen combatants with
Able’s level of fighting prowess among the
ranks of the Court of Owls and League of Assassins,
ancient orders of killers who operated in
secret.
Maybe this barbaric fighter was part of such
an organization, maybe Able had been watching
him?
The Detective watched and pondered over possible
connections to Ra’s Al Ghul, Talon and even
Azrael as Able took on the mountainous mercenary.
He had ducked out of the way of an oncoming
swipe, rolling between the wrestler’s legs
in an open stance.
Having outflanked Bane, before he had a chance
to turn around and face him, Able jumped upwards,
a pair of his black, reflective swords in
hand.
Slashing both through the air, he severed
the tubes on Bane’s back, part of a harness
designed to pump the Venom chemical into his
body and enhance his strength.
Sickly green fluid spewed from the pipes,
with Bane reaching his muscular arms behind
him, fumbling with the mechanism, desperately
trying to repair the device that kept his
body strong.
It was too late, the luchador dropped to his
knees and collapsed, defeated as Able stood
over him with his swords in hand.
“You can come out now, Bat!” he called
up to the ceiling.
“By now, you have no doubt guessed that
I’m not here for this one.
It’s you they sent me to find.”
Never one to charge headfirst into a fight
without thought, Batman dropped a smoke pellet.
It burst as it made contact with the concrete
floor below, filling the area around Able
with a heavy, grey fog that was impossible
for the warrior to see through.
A trio of sharp-tipped Batarangs came spinning
through the air; Able barely had a chance
to see them coming in time to block them with
his swords, only to be caught off guard as
an attack struck him from behind.
Dropping from above, Batman landed a devastating
gliding kick, knocking Able to the ground.
The barbarian rolled over, angered at the
outmaneuver, as Batman stood casting a towering,
pointy-eared shadow over him.
“Who are you?”
Batman demanded in the deep, authoritative
voice of a grizzled veteran vigilante.
“I am known by many names,” the man replied,
the Detective taking note of his distinctive
Middle Eastern accent.
“You will call me Able, the man who will
be your undoing.”
“Tell me who sent you,” the Dark Knight
retorted, adding, “Or else.”
Able chuckled dryly before swinging one of
his swords downwards.
Blocking it with his gauntlets, Batman trapped
the blade between the row of claws on his
forearms, before using them to snap the weapon
in two.
Just as Able went to stab at him with his
other one, the Dark Knight spun out of the
way, grabbing his opponent’s hand and guiding
the weapon away in a smooth parry, telling
of his years of martial arts training.
But, with both hands holding Able’s attack
aloft, Batman couldn’t prevent the barbarian
from pulling yet another blade from his pocket
dimension.
With a slash from a smaller knife, Able cleaved
open the grey and black costumed that the
Caped Crusader wore, causing him a serious
injury.
Grunting in pain, Batman headbutted Able square
in the nose, causing him to reel back, still
chuckling at the tenacity of his target.
“Impressive,” Able mused.
“The Foundation sent me here to kill you.
I wasn’t expecting to find such a worthy
adversary.”
He slowly lowered his swords, while Batman
kept his fists raised in a fighting stance.
“I will not be their puppet.
You and I are both warriors,” the barbarian
stated.
“I’m not a killer,” Batman argued.
“Perhaps, but you are a fighter, and a fighting
man does not deserve to be killed like a sheep,
at the behest of cowards and fools… you
deserve a warrior’s death,” Able replied.
“Two hours from now, midnight.
We meet atop the tallest building in this
wretched city.
There and then, that is when you die at my
hand.”
With that, Able turned and walked away.
Batman thought about going after him, tackling
him to the ground and restraining him.
But he was still wounded, he needed time to
recuperate.
“I checked the records, sir.
There is no mention of any metahuman with
the power to create weapons on either the
ARGUS or STAR Labs databases,” Alfred explained
over Batman’s earpiece.
After a quick retreat to the cave to tend
to his injury, Bruce was already racing back
out into the night, careening through the
streets of Gotham in the Batmobile.
“What about the ‘Foundation’ that Able
mentioned?” he asked Alfred.
“Not much luck there either, Master Bruce,”
his faithful butler answered.
“There is one mention of an organization
called the ‘SCP Foundation’ in an old
ARGUS document, but the majority of the file
has been redacted.
The only reference to it is in an addendum
that someone must have forgotten to remove.”
“Good work, Alfred,” Batman responded.
“There’s one person in this city who might
be able to give me more information.”
“Oh, heavens, you don’t mean…”
“Who else has a knack for knowing too much?”
The cell was quiet, lit only by the low flickering
of fluorescent bulbs that hung from the ceiling
of Arkham Asylum.
It had been hours since the guards had called
for the inmates to go to bed, although they
were no less alert.
Any one of them could break out at any time.
And there was one who’d been waiting for
his chance rather patiently.
“Riddle me this,” Edward said aloud, aware
of a figure approaching his cell.
“I am always around but unseen.
I am often avoided but never outrun.
I could find you at the end of the road or
even the next corner.
What am I?”
“Death,” Batman answered monotonously.
“To what do I owe the pleasure, Dark Knight?”
the Riddler asked.
“I need information,” the Caped Crusader
replied.
“And you’ve got more than your fair share.”
“After a decade of rivalry, the Detective
decides to come crawling to me for answers,
to offer some recognition of my brilliance!”
“Not brilliance, Edward.
Persistence,” he corrected.
“Hm, you’re as cheery as ever,” the
Riddler chuckled.
“The SCP Foundation, what do you know?”
He peered over the rim of his glasses, offering
Batman a wry smile.
“If you know me, you’ll want to share
me.
If you share me, I’ll be gone.
What am I?” he asked.
“A secret.”
“Oh, they certainly are!”
Edward exploded with laughter.
“The Foundation are an odd bunch.
They’d even make some of the patients here
at good old Arkham seem sane by comparison.
Think of them as the resident experts in unusual
phenomena, ‘anomalies’ they call them,”
the maniac obsessed with mind games explained.
“They are everywhere, all across the world,
an organization older and with more reach
than any you’ve encountered.
And oh me, oh my, the things that they have
locked away... monsters that would scare even
you, Batman.”
“How do I know this isn’t another one
of your delusions, Riddler?”
Batman barked, banging a fist against the
bars to intimidate his nemesis.
“Don’t insult me, Dark Knight!
You and I both know you wouldn’t have come
to me if you were going to disbelieve what
I had to say,” the Riddler yelled.
“And mark my words, if the Foundation has
its sights on you, well…
Riddle me this –”
Already Batman had turned and started walking
away down the corridor.
“My inventor doesn’t want me, the man
who bought me won’t need me, and the man
who needs me doesn’t know it.
What am I?”
The Dark Knight paused a few feet from the
cell.
“A coffin.”
“It could all be a trick, sir,” Alfred
urged as Bruce departed the Asylum.
“Edward Nashton is hardly a reliable source
of information.”
“He has a compulsion to always prove himself
as the smartest, to always be right,” Batman
replied, “What I still can’t understand
is why this Foundation would send Able to
kill me?
What’s the connection between them and me?”
“Perhaps, Master Bruce, it’s less what
connects you and more how you could be an
obstacle to them,” the butler reasoned.
“If this Foundation are experts in unusual
phenomena, then there are an abundance of
such things here in Gotham.
Everything from the copious super criminals
to the giant coin here in the Batcave.”
“And with me out of the way,” Batman began
to catch on.
“They’d have free reign,” Alfred finished
the sentence.
“In sending a madman to kill you, it’s
clear they didn't come to play fair, sir.”
The clocktower in the middle of Gotham let
out an ominous ‘bong’, marking the approach
of midnight.
“Then neither will I,” Batman replied.
Able had been waiting atop the roof of a skyscraper,
the name ‘Wayne Enterprises’ emblazoned
on its front.
It was almost midnight, there were minutes
left, but the barbarian was still confident
the Bat would show.
He could almost taste the adrenaline of their
looming battle, anticipating their final showdown.
Able could hardly wait to have a worthy opponent
to best in combat.
The sound of some kind of advanced aircraft
whooshed overhead, and the barbaric warrior
craned his neck upwards.
Soaring above was the Batplane, set against
the backdrop of the night sky with a single
beam of light reaching up into the clouds,
projecting the Dark Knight’s insignia above:
the Bat Signal.
Parachuting down, Batman had donned a heavily
armored battle suit over his costume.
He’d originally designed it to go toe to
toe with Superman in case his closest ally
ever went rogue, but the armor’s bulkier
plating would easily be more resistant to
the ferocious damage Able could dish out.
He landed on the rooftop with a thud, as Able
jeered in disgust.
“Coward!” he spat.
“You are not the honorable fighter I mistook
you for.
Just another pretender like that luchador,
giving yourself an advantage rather than rely
on your skill!
Are you so afraid of me that you’d encase
yourself in armor?”
“Are you afraid that you’ll lose?”
Batman replied calmly.
Roaring in anger, Able charged towards Batman,
pulling a fresh pair of swords from his pocket
dimension.
He swung the blades through the air, only
for them to clang off the thick plating protecting
the Caped Crusader’s arms as he lifted his
gauntlets to block the incoming attacks.
Immediately, feral, bloodthirsty rage on his
face, Able swiped again, this time directing
his weapon to a tiny gap where Batman’s
helmet met the rest of his suit at the neck.
The sword stayed lodged between the armor,
only for Batman to pull back and launch a
devastating punch that sent Able staggering
back.
“I built this suit to survive hits from
a Kryptonian.
Trust me, you won’t even scratch it,”
Batman declared.
“Give it up, Able, walk away.
Tell the Foundation to stay out of Gotham.”
Seeing red, noticing one of his weapons was
still stuck at the join in Batman’s armor,
Able let out a mighty yell and ran towards
his adversary.
Stomping forward to clash with him head-on,
Batman started moving as fast as the bulky
Batsuit would allow him.
But, moments before the pair of them collided,
Able dropped, skidding along the rooftop under
Batman’s legs, using the size and weight
of his opponent’s armor to his advantage;
just like he had done with Bane earlier.
Before Batman had a chance to turn around,
Able leaped onto his feet and grabbed his
cape, pulling the Dark Knight over and causing
his heavy armor to topple.
Batman clattered down onto his back, and Able
gripped the sword that had gotten stuck.
With one hand gripping the Bat by his cape,
the barbarian used the other to grab his weapon,
trying to lever off his opponent’s protective
helmet.
Struggling to get himself free, Batman reached
for his belt, throwing a barrage of batarangs
that spun through the air, only to return
and strike Able in the chest.
He barely registered the impact, shrugging
off the projectiles as if they were made of
paper.
“You cannot win!
Even if you could best me, I always come back,”
Able grunted, feeling his sword breaking through
the join in Batman’s armor.
“I am Able, I am immortal!
But underneath all your tools and tricks,
you are nothing but a man.
Now do what men do and die.”
A sudden, winding blow stuck Able square in
the chest.
Batman had activated the heartbeat sensors
in his helmet’s eyepieces, and sent both
his armor-plated fists rocketing upwards,
connecting with the barbarian’s heart.
Reeling, Able staggered back, trying to catch
his breath, as Batman stood to his feet, the
hulking, unmistakable silhouette towering
over the immortal warrior.
“I’m not just a man,” he growled.
“I am vengeance!”
Bam!
His words were punctuated by another devastating
punch to the same spot.
“I am the night!”
Pow!
Once more, the Dark Knight struck Able in
the heart, sending him closer to the edge
of the roof.
“I am Batman!”
A thundercrack rang out, as Able looked up
wheezing at his adversary.
“You…
you will not kill me, Bat,” he rasped.
“No, I won’t,” Batman answered, leaning
in close.
“You always come back.”
With a final uppercut, he knocked Able over
the ledge, sending the barbarian careening
down into the Gotham Reservoir below.
Despite being exhausted from their encounter,
Batman scoured the reservoir for any signs
of Able’s remains.
He couldn’t find anything, there was no
body, but something told the Dark Knight that
the undying barbarian would be back.
From a distant rooftop, a pair of Foundation
operatives were watching through night vision
scopes.
“Well, that seemed a little excessive,”
one remarked to the other.
“Didn’t think he was the type to show-off.”
“I don’t think that was showing off,”
the other replied.
“I think that was a warning.”
Now go and check out “DEADPOOL VS SCP-682
THE HARD TO DESTROY REPTILE” and “SCP-073
& 076 CAIN VS ABLE”! for more badass battles
from SCP Explained!